hey you guys doing another movie review
today this movie is a little bit of a
weird one I'm actually not even really
sure where I first heard of this movie
from probably on one of those like
underrated horror movie lists or
something like that cuz I kind of look
through those every now and then like
looking for ideas and this movie it's
one that I don't really hear anybody
ever talking about I don't even know if
a lot of people have heard of this one
but I actually really really dug this
one a lot and I think more people should
see it now I'm going to say like right
out the gate it's not exactly a horror
movie I would call it kind of more like
a Cohen Brothers style crime Thriller
that also is sort of interwoven with a
kind of understated romantic
comedy/drama I know that sounds strange
but the end result of the movie is
actually not as weird as it sounds and
I'm going to say that even though kind
of the jux toos of the two genres is
pretty audacious uh particularly for a
first-time director which uh this is it
somehow really works it kind of makes
this movie just very gripping and it has
these kind of two disparate plot lines
that for a long time they don't like you
don't really know how they connect or
anything but they end up really nicely
complimenting one another like when they
eventually do kind of converge um and
I'm going to say if you're looking for
some real like [__] nail-biting
suspense uh then this movie has that in
Spades so this movie came out in 2015
and it's called Uncle John now this was
directed by um Stephen Patt I think is
how you pronounce his last name he also
directed the second season of the Sci-Fi
series Channel Zero which is very good
if you haven't seen it it might be on um
shudder at the moment uh his season was
called no end house if you don't know
Channel Zero is basically they each
season is like based on a different like
Creepy Pasta uh so yeah so he directed
that one and that one's really good so
this movie it starts out and I'm going
to say like right out the gate this
discussion will have spoilers so if you
haven't seen this movie and you know you
don't want to know what happens in it
then probably don't listen to the rest
of the video but if you have seen it or
you don't care or you figure you'll see
it and by by the time you see it you
forgot what I said about it anyway which
is usually what happens to me so don't
feel bad um then continue all you want
so this movie Uncle John it starts out
by introducing us to the Title Character
Uncle John who is this very stoic but
also pretty friendly Wisconsin Carpenter
now he's played by John Ashton you know
ve veteran character actor um now right
at the beginning of the movie he's right
in the middle this starts right out the
gate he's right in the middle of uh
murdering a dude you know and uh
meticulously covering up the crime too I
might add so right away like since this
is the first scene like the movie just
sucks you right in especially because
nothing is really explained like right
off the bat and since disposing of a
body in a bonfire in broad daylight
which is what he's doing you kind of see
him doing that and then like the next
scene he's kind of seen being real
neighborly and you know this well Ed
member of this small farming Community
where he lives and he's sitting with his
all like old dude buddies at the local
cafe and they're just like hanging out
and shooting the [__] or whatever so
you're watching it and just like what
was that murder thing all about like is
this dude a serial killer or what but
before we get any definitive answers to
that question uh the movie seems to
Barrel off in a completely different
direction now we're in this kind of HIP
Chicago advertising firm um filled with
kind of Scruffy millennials
so you have a graphic designer named Ben
he's played by Alex Moffett and he's
being introduced to his new manager
who's this beautiful young woman named
Kate he's played by uh Jenna Ling or uh
Lang I'm not really sure how you
pronounce her last name uh so he's
obviously like really you know attracted
to her immediately so they have kind of
like some sweet and genuine like banter
back and forth and there are hints that
some romance may be developing between
these two you know pretty appealing
characters like in the very near future
and then we're back to the murder in Loi
Wisconsin where we learn that the man
that Uncle John murdered was named Dutch
and that he wasn't uh a particularly
popular dude around town let's put it
that way evidently he had [__] a bunch
of people over but had just recently had
a vision in which he had seen hell and
so he had subsequently like given his
life over to Jesus right like he became
a boor again Christian so he had spent
the previous few weeks kind of going to
all the towns folk that he had wronged
and trying to make amends but obviously
the wrong that he did to Uncle John
whatever it was uh was too big for
forgiveness I guess um so when the dude
disappears like we know what happened to
him but nobody else does um nobody in
town seems terribly put out about it um
you know cuz like I said nobody really
liked the dude all that much even though
he was born again and everything and the
police are kind of operating on the
assumption that he maybe just got drunk
and drowned in the lake however Dutch's
shady ass brother whose name is Danny
has a hunch that Dutch was murdered and
he is bound and determined to find out
who did it so meanwhile uh back in
Chicago Ben and Kate are kind of having
some will they won't they type
interactions and even though it kind of
sounds dismissive when I say it like
that these two characters really are
adorable and funny and they really were
kind of like a pleasure to watch and I
really do not like like romantic
comedies or chick flicks or anything
like that so that's you know quite a
recommendation coming for me cuz
normally this kind of stuff just makes
me roll my eyes you know what I mean so
the deal is Kate has just left this long
relationship uh with a coworker and it
went kind of badly so she's deciding
that she's not going to be dating any
more co-workers in the near future which
you know obviously Ben's kind of bummed
out about that Ben decides he's going to
be her friend anyway though like I guess
hoping eventually that she'll see the
light and like be like oh my God you're
the guy for me or whatever now somewhere
around this stage in the movie we
finally figure out what the relationship
is between the two parallel plots cuz up
to now it's just been kind of going back
and forth between and you're like what
the [__] does one have to do with the
other you know what I mean it turns out
that Uncle John back in Loi Wisconsin is
Ben's uncle and that Jon raised him
after Ben's mother was killed in an
accident and then after he was abandoned
by his dad so Ben pretty much has
nothing but praise for Uncle John I mean
he clearly loves him and admires him a
great deal cuz he was pretty much like
his father figure you know what I mean
so back in Loi the search for the
missing Dutch continues and Dany his
brother is getting more and more
suspicious particularly of JN although
JN uh just basically keeps his little
Midwestern affability intact um I got to
say I've seen John Ashton uh in a lot of
movies he's been a [__] ton of movies
obviously but I think this might be my
favorite role of his that I've seen he's
just so so good as this this quiet
friendly small town guy who decides he's
basically just going to like take care
of business like just on the down low
and he is like the last person that
anyone would suspect of doing such a
thing you know what I mean but then like
when he does do it it's not completely
unbelie unbelievable you know what I
mean so it's like a good it's like a I I
feel like it would be like a difficult
line for an actor to walk but he does it
like really really well and that's kind
of the great thing about this movie is
that
despite the fact that you know that
Uncle John is a murderer and you know
you can't super justify like what he did
to the dude you know what I mean but you
still can't help but like love the guy
and kind of defend his actions
especially when you learn later on in
the movie that Jon actually killed Dutch
because Dutch had been having an affair
with his sister who was Ben's mother and
had treated her just like atrociously
and that him leaving her actually like
prompted her to commit suicide so back
in Chicago Ben and Kate are working some
kind of like weekend overtime together
at the office and then they decide they
want to break for coffee and donuts as
you do now they initially plan to go
somewhere kind of nearby but then Ben
says you know I've never had any donuts
as good as the ones in my hometown which
is loai Wisconsin so on a whim uh you
know it's the weekend Kate suggests that
they kind of finish up their work and
then take this 2 and 1 half hour drive
out to Loi to visit the place where Ben
grew up cuz she's you know getting kind
of curious because like I said they're
kind of like getting to like each other
you know what I mean so they're like
well maybe we can spend the whole
weekend like visiting Uncle John like
wouldn't that be kind of cool so at this
point you know this is where the two
plots like actually like come together
and converge like when they all meet up
in the same place so when Ben and Kate
get to Loi um Uncle John is surprised to
see them obviously because they didn't
really call ahead which seems a little
bit rude but whatever and so they get
there and especially you know he's
especially surprised because Danny
Dutch's brother has been kind of
sniffing around and sort of like making
veiled threats toward him and like at
the house but everybody kind of puts on
friendly faces Dany even stays over at
J's house while Ben and Kate like Grill
some steaks out on the grill or whatever
but after he starts trying to like
needle Jon about his sister's death like
JN kind of takes him aside and has some
words with him and then Danny kind of
storms off so Ben and Kate who are
completely clueless as to what's been
going on this whole time wonder you know
what got up his butt or whatever but
then like John kind of covers for him
and said oh he just had to go to work
and whatever so he's just trying to like
blow it off you know but as the evening
goes on tensions start to melt you just
know that Danny is going to come back
and do something bad and because you've
spent so much time getting to know Ben
and Kate and Uncle John you really
really don't want anything bad to happen
to them and it's like this is like um a
Triumph of like the characterization
because you really like these characters
you're like oh [__] you really don't
want anything bad Happ happen to them
now and you especially don't want Ben
and Kate to get caught in the crossfire
of kind of all this Intrigue especially
because they have no idea like what's
been going on this whole time and no
idea that Jon is actually a murderer so
then two things kind of start to happen
so Ben and Kate who are still kind of
playing the Just Friends game and
they're sleeping in different rooms but
both of them come downstairs at the same
time you know ostensibly to see if the
other one is up so yeah they end up um I
don't I don't think they [__] or
anything but they do end up like kind of
kissing and stuff and we're kind of like
Yay because you know honestly they're
they're cute and like we've been rooting
for them like I said they're very
likable characters and you did want to
see them get together which coming from
somebody like me that does not like
chick-flicks or romantic comedies that's
saying a lot however outside Dany has
indeed come back just like we feared
that he would he has a can of gasoline
with him and he has a gun in his
waistband what he doesn't know though is
that Uncle John who is not stupid uh has
already assumed that Danny would be
coming back and he's hiding in the barn
with a rifle like just waiting for that
eventuality and after that there comes
what I think was like the best sequence
in the movie it's absolutely stomach
churning I was just kind of like I was
just like messed up with like Dread the
whole time so it so it's kind of it's
not a super long sequence but it's
really really well done I like it's
really suspenseful so Danny's like
looking at the house kind of fiddling
with his gun and we can clearly see like
Ben and Kate through the window Windows
as they kind of like finally act on
their attraction after all this time
like they start kissing or whatever and
like maybe it's dumb but I was kind of
like oh man please do not let this end
the way it looks like it's going to um
cuz I really liked these two and they
didn't even do anything they don't even
know what's going on um it looks bad for
them though and uh and I admit that I
really really did not want to keep
watching at this point because I said if
this ends like it looks like it's going
to end then I'm going to be really
really upset but thankfully and again
you know this is a discussion that has
spoilers I said that at the beginning
but I'm saying it again right now it it
so happens that Jon kind of emerges from
the barn and whacks Dany quietly upside
the head with the rifle butt then very
slowly and silently just squeezes the
[__] life out of him before he can go
into the house and you know thereby
saving his nephew and his nephew's new
love interest without them even knowing
that they were in danger so this is
actually like a
weirdly touching scene because it shows
how this kind of like salt of the earth
small town old guy is basically willing
to murder and go to jail to save his
adopted son even though like by his
facial expression and like I said this
is some great [__] acting by John
Ashton here you can tell that JN really
did not want to have to do this you know
what I mean but he was just did it cuz
he had to you know so Ben and Kate like
head back to Chicago the next morning
neither of them the wiser like what
happened and they have this discussion
in the car on the way home about all of
Kate's crazy relatives and how normal
Ben's Uncle John is and while they're
having this discussion the movie kind of
intercuts it with Uncle John burning
Danny's body like in a bonfire in the
Quarry so this cop car pulls up behind
him and you're just like like uh-oh like
jigs up cuz you don't want him to get
caught you know what I mean even though
you know but you know what I mean you
still don't want him to get caught but
really the cop is just there to tell
John oh hey um just FYI now Danny's
missing and you might want to watch out
for yourself because Danny was going
around town thinking thinking um that
somebody murdered his brother and you
know he might be dangerous so you might
want to look out for him or whatever you
know irony so John skates uh but we
don't know for how long like will he get
caught eventually will he get away with
it we don't really know so as I said
before because for a large percentage of
the movie It's kind of going back and
forth between what seems like two
completely different genres you have
kind of like a hardboiled crime Thriller
kind of thing not hardboiled I guess but
it's kind of like a rural crime Thriller
type situation like a Cohen Brothers
movie but um but not funny and then you
have this kind of like romantic drama
comedy thing going on like on the thing
and then it just keeps going back and
forth between them like until they meet
in the middle so it sounds like on paper
it sounds like it shouldn't really work
but it totally totally does so like the
two plots while they're completely
different like on the surface actually
kind of complement and comment on one
another in a whole bunch of different
ways amid the film's themes I think are
how little you actually know about maybe
like the dark sides of those that you
love and how parents whether biological
or otherwise um will basically sacrifice
everything to keep their children from
harm you know even if that means
covering up a murder or two you know so
as I mentioned not exactly a horror
movie it does have some kind of horror
elements to it but it's more kind of
like a crime Thriller but it you know it
is it's fantastic it's like really
really suspenseful had some really
really good acting performances in it
and the third act just kind of had me
perched on the edge of my [__] chair
and so anxious that I almost didn't want
to finish it you know what I mean
because I liked the characters the
buildup the characters had been so good
that I was really invested in them and I
was just like and I I was like oh my God
if something bad happens to him I'm
going to like [__] scream you know
what I mean like I was really I was
going to get really upset but you know
they they manage that really well so I
would recommend this if you're into like
I said Cohen Brothers movies or if you
really like crime Thrillers or you just
kind of like maybe odd mashups it's not
that odd um you know like I said on
paper it sounds strange but when you see
it in the movie It's not that strange
although at first I was just kind of
like like you know you see the dude
murdering somebody and then suddenly
we're you know in Chicago with these
Millennials and stuff I'm just like wait
what the [__] is going on but like once
you kind of get into the groove of it
it's not really all that weird but yeah
I feel like I have not heard another
single person other than the person that
recommended it on whatever list it was
like years ago um I've really never hear
anybody talking about this and it's
really kind of a shame cuz I really
really liked this movie a lot and I
think that uh more people should see it
I don't actually even know where it's
streaming at the moment I think I
watched it on maybe Hulu but it was a
while back so I don't know if it's still
on there or not but maybe you can find
it someplace I'm not really sure cuz
more people should see it cuz I think
it's really good that will do it for
flickers of fear hope you guys enjoyed
it please remember to like share
subscribe comment and all of that good
stuff and I will see you guys again on
the next one bye